go a statically typed compiled language
often described as c for the 21st
century it's a popular choice for
high-performance server-side
applications and is the language that
built tools like docker cockroachdb and
d-graph it was created at google in 2007
by legends who really know their stuff
like ken thompson the inventor of the b
and c programming languages version 1.0
was released as open source software in
2012. it was designed for simplicity and
efficiency and that's why we call it go
and not go lang the source code is
compiled down to machine code which
means it generally outperforms
interpreted languages but it's famous
for its extremely fast compile times
made possible by innovations to
dependency analysis and even though it's
a statically typed language it performs
type inference to deliver a syntax that
is very concise and practical it also
has a package and module system making
it easy to import and export code
between projects to get started install
go and then open an empty directory on
your system create a file ending in go
then add package main at the top to
create a standalone executable then
declare a main function which is where
your program will start executing go has
a standard library of core packages to
handle common requirements like math
networking or formatted io by importing
fmt we can print a line to the standard
output then run the go build command and
it quickly compiles the source code and
dependencies into an executable binary
when it comes to dependencies we can
also link to remote packages on github
run go mod init from the command line
and that creates a go module file that
enables dependency tracking
syntactically go is like a concise
version of c or c plus plus declare a
variable with the var keyword followed
by its name and type and initialize it
with a value or you might use the short
assignment syntax to replace var and let
go automatically infer the type and you
can define multiple variables from a
single line go has all the other
features you would expect in a
programming language like arrays maps
loops and control flow but also allows
you to store the memory address of a
value using pointers while disallowing
pointer arithmetic which often leads to
dangerous and unpredictable behavior in
addition it supports concurrency with go
routines which are functions that can
run at the same time as other functions
by utilizing multiple threads on a cpu
this has been go in 100 seconds hit the
like button if you want to see more
short videos like this and check out the
full article to write your first 100
lines of go on fireship io thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one